[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or i bar est un groupe japonais aurient
bat france et une de ses filiales où est
basé un centre d'excellence horiba
fournit des solutions de mesure de
métrologie pour la science et
l'industrie et notre raison d'être est
d'accélérer l'innovation par la
connaissance
le focus de notre développement est
aujourd'hui dans des domaines de
l'énergie et les matériaux mais
également les sciences de la vie et puis
les semi conducteurs dans les trois cas
on apporte par le croisement de
technologie historiquement technologies
optiques des solutions innovantes qui
nous permettent
d'accélérer le développement chez nos
clients de nouveaux produits donc on
intervient dans les domaines de la r&d
mais également dans le domaine de la
production pour faire du contrôle de
procédé et améliorer le contrôle qualité
et la productivité de nos clients
horiba était visionnaire de s'installer
sur le plateau de saclay dès 2012 donc
fait partie des premières sociétés à
avoir choisi
palaiseau et de le plateau de saclay
pour son implantation pour son centre
d'excellence
ça c'est pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
pour l'environnement académique on
cherche à attirer des talents dans le
domaine de la recherche qui nous
aideront à concevoir les instruments de
demain on cherche également à dans le
développement de ces instruments a
collaboré étroitement avec un tissu
académique proches également il est
important d'avoir des partenaires
industriels
qui vont pouvoir nous aider à développer
les bons produits en volume et depuis un
certain nombre d'années dans le domaine
de l'énergie mais également dans le
domaine des sciences de la vie on voit
de plus en plus de partenaires
industriels qui peuvent remplir cette
fonction est donc l'écosystème à la fois
académique et industriel est un gros
plus pour nous et puis enfin au niveau
des talents pour nous il est important
de pouvoir
être dans un
un pôle qui a tiré et fait grandir des
étudiants qui deviendront les employés
de riba de demain on a presque une
centaine de postes aujourd'hui ouvert et
donc on recrute dans tous les domaines
on a besoin aujourd'hui de beaucoup de
renforts et je vous invite à rejoindre
une société en pleine dynamique qui
travaillent sur des problématiques
sociétales d'avenir et où il ya une
véritable passion de la technologie
[Musique]